[Music]
we're approaching another solemn moment
in the pandemic the loss of 600 thousand
lives in america due to the coronavirus
in a new book
a former white house senior advisor for
coveted response argues much of this
disaster could have been prevented
andy slavitt left president biden's
covert response team just last week
after taking on the position in january
his new book offers
an up close look at the crisis and how
leaders responded it's called
preventable the inside story of how
leadership failures politics and
selfishness
doomed the u.s coronavirus response and
andy slabbitt joins us now andy good
morning to you
good to have you with us you know i had
a complicated question to start with but
my co-host this morning adriana diaz
suggested a far simpler one the book is
called preventable
how much of this pandemic was
preventable and how
well of course we would have had a
pandemic here in the u.s no matter what
um
but but and look we can count the the
mistakes and i think it's important that
we do
if for nothing else so we don't repeat
them we obviously had a set of technical
mistakes
with the testing and and the the ppe
that we know about
but if we're honest we also had two or
two other types of mistakes that caused
a lot of loss of life one were just
plainly political leadership mistakes
um there was a lot we denied the virus
for too long out of the trump white
house
there was too much squashing of dissent
and playing on divisions but i'd also
think we all need to look at one another
and ask ourselves what do we need to do
better next time and in many respects
being able to sacrifice a little bit for
one another
to get through this and to save more
lives is going to be is going to be
essential and that's something
that i think we could all have done a
little bit better on so when we look in
the mirror and evaluate our own role in
all this the public
how we could have sacrificed more as you
say and we think about the possibility
of a difficult fall or winter or a
difficult variant
what more needs to be done now to
prepare ourselves as a public putting
aside the government and the scientific
part of this for us
is the public what's the message
well there's a couple simple things one
is that
that all the people that for so long
live so close to the edge
that don't have a great safety net that
don't have great health insurance
but they're forced to work day in and
day out to serve us they're growing
crops
they're delivering food to our
warehouses they're they're working in
grocery stores they're delivering food
to our door
all those people are at risk all the
time and and so we have to we there's a
chapter in the book called the room
service pandemic
and it talks about how a lot of us had
had it quite okay during the pandemic
and
others didn't so we should be looking at
that and then look preventing
the spread of the disease is really
about a couple simple things not
breathing near one another in large
spaces
that's really that's really it if you
want to be overly simple about it
and that requires a certain amount of
sacrifice and change it's a short period
of time
and we none of us can do it forever and
it's not pleasant
but but when we do we reduce the amount
of spread pretty dramatically and if the
variants come back in the fall
as as they will the people who are
unvaccinated really are going to need to
pay
serious attention to that and consider
getting vaccinated because we have some
great vaccines on the market
so andy in terms of what may happen in
the future do you think that we are
ready for another pandemic which
inevitably is going to come and affect
us
i don't think we are and i don't think
we are for a couple reasons um
one is i think we need to have a
dialogue in this country
about about what matters is it more
important for us to have our individual
liberties
that we don't wear a mask or should is
there some common good
that we should all be working towards i
think we'll do better job technically i
think we will
we will put the money into public health
that we need i think we'll have woken up
a little bit i also think our experience
with the pandemic will hopefully allow
us to respond better but a divided
country
with leaders that play against our
greatest fears which
divide us and if they didn't if we deny
science we're going to have
trouble again so hopefully we'll learn
some of those lessons do you uh
you mentioned the vaccination rate i
mean it's 64
of american adults have had at least one
shot the hope is by the by
administration we get to 70
by july 4th questionable whether we will
get there
but there's still a lot of resistance to
vaccinations
how important is it do you think that we
get this number up significantly higher
well look i think there's a lot of us to
whom taking a vaccine
wasn't a very involved decision we made
it right away we wanted to get
vaccinated we knew he did
there's a number a number of other
people and they're not necessarily
anti-vaccine but they just want more
information and it takes a little bit
more time
and so we have to we have to respect
that process even
if we're not going to vaccinate people
as quickly as possible i'm confident
that that over time we will begin to
vaccinate those people but we have to
make sure
is that they don't go to places like
facebook to get information about
vaccines but go to reliable sources if
you're not sure if
your should get vaccinated ask your
doctor ask your pharmacist talk to
people you know have been vaccinated
don't follow the mythology around
vaccination because we have three
great vaccines that people all around
the world would love to have
it's causing great pain and suffering if
you look across the world
we're lucky to have them but if you need
more information get more information
we do have some great vaccines andy we
also have the first and what will be i'm
sure a shelf of books looking back
uh on what happened and why with this
pandemic and how it could be different
in the future yours is the first entry
and a great one uh andy slavitt thank
you very much
the book preventable goes on sale
tomorrow